REDHAT:
Servers are something that most
people never give much thought to. They’re simply
the background machines that make the modern world
go round. But the world of servers is actually
far more fascinating than you might think. The
global server market is worth $90 billion and a
lot of household names serve the cloud and server
market as well. This includes Amazon, Google,
Microsoft, Dell, Oracle, and Cisco. With this
many big players, you would think that the server
market is cutthroat and extremely competitive,
especially given that their entire customer base
is other sophisticated companies as opposed to
the general public. But what if I told you that
the server market has also been monopolized,
not by any of the common culprits like
Google or Amazon but actually IBM. You see,
96.3% of the world’s top web servers all
use the same OS Linux. For perspective,
even Windows and Android only have 70% market
share. Now, traditionally, Linux is an open source
operating system that isn’t owned by any one
entity and is completely free to use. But this is
not the sort of Linux that companies use. Instead,
companies prefer to use an enterprise version of
Linux. There are a couple of popular distributions
in this market like Ubuntu, Mint, and Fedora. But,
one distro rises above everyone else: Red Hat.
Red Hate Linux is basically the default choice
for companies and especially large companies.
In fact, over 90% of the Fortune 500 uses some
sort of enterprise solution from Red Hat. For the
longest time, Red Hat was just a background shadow
company that the general public had no clue about.
But, 4 years ago, IBM decided to change that by
purchasing the entirety of Red Hat for a cool $34
billion. So, now, it’s IBM that controls basically
the entire enterprise server OS market. But, how
did we even get here? How did one company end up
getting so much control over entire world’s tech
infrastructure? Well, join me, as we take a look
back at the monumental rise of Red Hat and the
landmark deal that has put IBM back on the map.
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS:
Speaking of legacy products
making a comeback, a classic investment that’s
making a comeback is bonds. You've probably heard
about stocks - buying a share of ownership in a
company. Bonds are different - you loan money to
governments and companies and they pay you back
with interest. Normally, bonds are seen as the
boring investment for old people because while
they’re generally safer than stock investing,
they also come along with lower returns of
1-3%. But, this has all changed with the new
high interest rate environment. The US federal
government themselves are paying 5% for bills
that are as short as 1 month to bonds that are as
long as 30 years. And companies are paying even
more. If you’d like to lock in high yields for
yourself for the short term or long term, please
consider checking out our upcoming bond investing
app Silo in the description below, but anyway
going back to RedHat, the story of RedHat dates
back 30 years to a bum named Robert Young. Robert
had huge ambitions of running his own company
and making it big in the business world. But,
the reality was that Robert was unemployed and
broke, working on “companies” in his wife’s sewing
closet. His latest endeavor was running a computer
supply catalog business. To get the word out about
this business, Robert would regularly attend local
tech conferences and try to network with as many
people as possible. It was during one of these
networking events that Robert would run into a
man named Marc Ewing. Marc was your classic 1980s
geek software engineer. He spent his childhood
summers attending computer camps and writing
programs for Apollo and Commodore computers.
Within his local community and especially his
college community, he would naturally become known
as the tech guy. Given that he liked wearing red
hats, people would begin referring to him as the
man in the red hat and the name stuck. Marc
wasn’t necessarily looking to start a massive
company like Robert though. In fact, it seems like
he preferred the traditional path as he would turn
around and get a job at IBM after college. In his
free time though, he would continue meddling with
side projects like trying to customize Linux
for enterprise use. This project is what would
lead Marc to the fateful conference where he met
Robert. Robert would convince Marc to let him sell
Marc’s Linux distros through his new computer
supply catalog business and this marked the
beginning of a legendary partnership. At first, it
was simply a distribution deal, Robert would sell
Marc’s Linux CDs but Robert would end up selling
out of these CDs so often that he knew that Marc
was onto something. So, in 1995, the two would
decide to join forces and create Red Hat Software
with Robert serving as the CEO. Despite forming
a company and having profit incentive though,
the duo never really strayed away from their
roots. They didn’t just go out and file a bunch
of patents and trademarks. Instead, they continued
to support the open source community as they
believed that open collaboration was the best way
to create software. This turned out to be a great
decision not just from a community perspective but
from a reach perspective. Being open source gave
Red Hat quite a bit of notoriety within the tech
community leading to a lot more adoption. By 1999,
RedHat would grow to just over $10 million
in annual revenue. This was a solid 8 figure
business that was realistically worth $30 to $50
million but combine this with the dotcom bubble
and things would get insane. They would launch the
IPO at a share price of $14 but by the end of the
first trading day itself, the share price would
rocket ot $52. And by the end of the second day,
the share price would rocket to $72, giving
the company a valuation of $4.8 billion. Red
Hat had gone from being a company that Robert
ran from his closet to a multi billion company
within just a matter of years. It almost seemed to
good to be true and that’s because it was. Moving
into the 2000s, Red Hat would face an existential
crisis as the company came back down to reality.
A HARSH REALITY CHECK:
The bottomline was that Red Hat was
extremely overhyped and overvalued at least from
a stock perspective, and it’s no wonder why. Many
investors saw Red Hat as the Windows of servers
and they weren’t wrong. Red Hat ended up becoming
way more dominant than even Windows in terms of
market share, but there’s two major difference.
First of all, Microsoft was already way bigger
than just Windows and two, there was a lot more
money to be made in the consumer market. And when
the market realized this, Red Hat stock would get
annihilated down to just $4 per share. To make
things worse, both Robert and Marc would leave
Red Hat in 1999 and 2002 respectively. They didn’t
leave on bad terms or anything, they actually left
on satisfied terms. Sure, they didn’t become
the next Bill Gates or Steve Jobs but they had
already made hundreds of millions each and they
were ready to enjoy life. You can’t really blame
them but they kind of did leave RedHat and all of
its employees out to dry. If all of this wasn’t
bad enough, Red Hat would also start to see
new competitors pop up. SUSE Linux Enterprise,
for example, came out in 2000. Ubuntu came out in
2004, and Oracle would follow up with their own
version in 2006. The value proposition of Red Hat
was starting to disappear despite them continuing
to win a bunch of awards. For example, they won
the Operating System Product of the Year award 4
year in a row. They would also be ranked number
1 for value 2 years in a row. But, while tech
media continued to be nice to Red Hat, they knew
that they had to do something different if they
really wanted to stick around. They started
thinking about their distro less as a piece
of software and more as a solution because well
the software itself doesn’t give them a very big
moat. Luckily for Red Hat, everyone was already
using their software, so the question wasn’t:
how do we get more customers but rather, how do we
keep the customers that we already have. And from
that perspective, the answer was easy: by offering
world class support. Support may not seem like a
big deal from a consumer perspective, but it’s
everything from an enterprise perspective. Keep
in mind, Red Hat is what’s keeping the entire tech
infrastructure of companies like Google and Amazon
up and running. And for companies at this scale,
even an hour of down time is tens of millions of
dollars lost. So, keeping the backend in pristine
condition and getting immediate support when it’s
not is of utmost importance. This is actually
quite ironic given that support was something
that Red Hat initially neglected. In fact, in the
early days, Robert would actually joke about how
the only way to reach Red Hat support was through
email which was counterintuitive given that if
your computer needed support, you probably
couldn’t email. But moving into the 2000s,
Red Hat would approach support from a completely
differentlight. In fact, they would add a bunch
of pricing tiers to their software that were
directly linked to the level of support they
came with. And let’s just say this gets pretty
expensive, as much as $2500 per license. But
with that being said, most large corporations
view this as a necessity and Red Hat very much
does live up to their price. They truly do offer
24x7 first class white glove tech support. It’s
easy to spin off another enterprise version of
Linux but matching the support and presence of
Red Hat is extremely difficult, and this made
way for a new wave of prosperity for Red Hat.
RESURRECTED DOMINANCE:
After this change in approach, Red
Hat would return to setting record after record.
In 2009, they would be added to the S&P 500 and
just 3 years later, they would become the first
open source company to reach a billion dollars in
annual revenue. By 2015, they would reach $2
billion and by 2018, they would reach nearly $3
billion. Red Hat was no longer the Dotcom boom
story that it was back in the 90s. By the late
2010s, Red Hat was a massive tech company offering
critical solutions to other massive companies,
making billions in the process. In the business
world though, when a company reaches extraordinary
heights, it’s only a matter of time until someone
else wants a piece of the pie. In the case of Red
Hat, it was the worn down legacy giant: IBM. What
IBM really needed was a face lift, a new way to
appeal to and attract customers because almost no
modern company really considered IBM as a serious
solution. They all flocked to AWS, Azure, Google,
and even Oracle Cloud before they considered IBM.
So, IBM decided to target a different demographic,
a more legacy demographic. Companies like Anthem,
American Airlines, Honeywell, Panasonic, Deloitte,
and Exxon. According to Arvind Krishna, the CEO
of IBM, most of these non tech companies are only
about 20% converted to cloud. So, the idea behind
buying RedHat for $34 billion is that this would
make IBM the one stop shop for legacy companies
who just want a simple straightforward reliable
solution. They don’t need the best performance
or the fastest response times or any of that. All
they want is a stress free migration to the cloud
and that’s exactly what IBM is looking to offer.
Things have been working out decently well from
IBM’s perspective, but many would argue that the
same cannot be said about Red Hat. It’s not that
IBM is making purposefully making bad choices
with RedHat or anything like that. In fact,
you could argue that IBM is genuinely trying
their best to respect the opensource nature of
RedHat while also trying to improve IBM cloud as
much as possible. As such, the problem seems to
be much more holistic and qualitative. Many would
argue that the bureaucratic old school ways of IBM
or simply rubbing off on RedHat and bringing down
the company. Much of RedHat’s leadership has left
the company following the acquisition and the
people who are left frankly only care about
their own compensation. They don’t know the
users and they don’t care about the product
because they’ve never even used it. This has led
to some really unpopular decisions like pushing
out unstable upstreams. With that being said
though, this does seem to be more of a case of
incompetence as opposed to any sort of malicious
intent. And as such, we have yet to see any sort
of large scale movement against Red Hat. But, the
vocal minority has already started raising several
valid red flags, and if IBM continues running Red
Hat in the same manner, a shift away from Red Hat
may very well be in the cards. So, the ball
is really in IBM’s court. They’ve somehow been
able to covertly overtake an extremely powerful
piece of software, but will they actually be able
to maintain Red Hat’s ubiquity and dominance
or will they fumble the ball, only time will
tell. If you’d like to take advantage of high
interest rates and have the government and top
companies pay you 4-7%, check out our upcoming
bond investing app Silo in the description below.